paris sous la tente comme chaque été le
seul camping de la capitale au bois de
boulogne affiche complet deux mille
touristes venus des quatre coins du
monde car là-bas le campeur français est
une espèce rare
reportage en version originale michel
périer pierre brasse caisse visite chez
ceux qui plante la tente au bois de
boulogne
voilà plusieurs fois que antonio manea
revient faire visiter paris à sa famille
alors qu'il ya 50 ans il a travaillé une
année en france j'avais travaillé qui
aiment unis et côté et j'avais un âne et
le bois de boulogne à ces campeurs ils
viennent de slovénie de colonne de
belgique d'espagne
pourtant la réputation du bois c'est
vrai ne tient pas à son camping mais il
est le seul à être situé près du centre
de paris la vie dans les campings est
différente parce qu'il n'y a aucun mur
qui sépare les gens
en fait je peux me promener partout
librement des beaux gosses
le ferez à lens
attention
sept hectares cosmopolite propice aux
rencontres sur wii a laissé le brésil
pour voyager avec sa fille non loin de
leur tante de petit matou voyage
amoureusement de la première fois que je
fais du camping et je pense que c'est
vraiment un très agréable plus sympa de
venir ici que d'aller à l'hôtel
c'est à un voyage d'amoureux